les 21 équipes qui participent au
concours universitaire ubisoft avait une
contrainte supplémentaire cette année
créer un jeu où les spectateurs
pourraient intervenir mena soir il n'y a
pas que le joueur qui est au centre
il y à l'audience les interactions entre
les deux les ce qu'on appelle les
streamer les questions ce qui diffuse le
contenu
et ça c'est le reflet concret de la
transformation de l'industrie
ils jouent en ligne fixe pour observer
la tarte x entraîne le sert qui tu peux
voter qu'un s'interdit sur le jeu le jeu
électronique n'est plus une activité
solitaire mais un divertissement qui
attire des milliers de spectateurs comme
le ferait un film ou un match de hockey
une grosse partie de la population qui
jouent aux jeux vidéo qui vont s'y
regarde et des procès où des célébrités
des cartes des personnages jouer à ces
jeux vidéo là pour avoir un
divertissement les spectateurs aux
autres peuvent ajouter des obstacles
commente le travail des genres un peu
plus de six semaines pour acheter un peu
de dynamisme pour faire en sorte que les
spectateurs puissent regarder en temps
réel et participez aussi l'intervention
du public se fait principalement dans le
club turc witch qui diffuse des parties
en direct est le viewer et il s'assoit
derrière et un écran que c'est un
extension de l'application switch qui
permet au choix de voter et de disputes
point faible de la créature on est plus
en plus habitué je dirais à regarder un
jeu qu'on mange quand ça devient un
passe temps comme on regarde une série
donc ça émergent de plus en plus
plusieurs sports comme le basket ball
ont même créé des équipes virtuelles
pour un public qui préfère la vidéo à la
réalité si on prend uniquement par
exemple la plateforme twitch depuis août
2010 8 on sait qu'à peu près 600
millions d'heures qui ont été consommés
à regarder du contenu de qui est qui a
trait à du jeu vidéo plusieurs milite
pour faire du sport électronique
une discipline olympique ici une seule
marsolais radio canada montréal